[Music]
my aunt Lyanna I've seen her stature in
the Crypt mother never talks about
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video lately I've been
thinking about making a video on Arya
Stark because I'm still trying to decide
how her story will end I have thought
about this topic a lot and I've already
made some videos on this in the past but
I'm still wondering if there is
something that I missed now that I've
been trying to see things from a
different angle whenever I think about
Arya Stark there is usually only two
ways I can see her story ending and I
think some of this is due to her
comparisons with Leone a stark these two
characters have led very different lives
but I can't help but wonder if they will
face a similar fate I think the very
first video I made about Arya Stark was
when I talked about some things that I
saw as foreshadowing for her death then
I made another video about Aria and
ginjury getting together now I know that
is a very popular topic but I believe I
was the first channel to make the Aria
and ginjury prediction video now that I
am talking about this again I still feel
like those are my two main thoughts
about how I can see her story ending
she's either going to die very young or
she will finally see the light and
decide to settle down and possibly start
a family of her own or at the very least
enter some kind of a relationship like I
have said before if Arya would happen to
die in the books
I believe she could live her second life
through her direwolf Nymeria but that's
obviously not as likely to happen in the
show because they never did introduce
her worgen abilities now when trying to
decide how Arya Starks story will land
we can go all the way back to the very
beginning of this story to see how some
of the pieces were being put in place
Aria had a conversation with her father
Ned Stark and they talked about her
future Ned told Aria that one day she
wouldn't marry a high Lord and rule his
castle and their sons would be knights
and princes but Aria said no that's not
me you will marry a high Lord and rule
his castle your son's shall be nice and
princes and Lords That's not me at the
time Aria had no intentions of living
her life as a lady like her sister
Songza wanted to ever since aria told
her father that she really hasn't shown
any signs of settling down and having a
family so it seems like aria will never
live that kind of a life whenever people
talk about Arya Stark in her future they
usually base it on what Aria said in
that scene because she said she never
wanted to get married and have kids so
we tend to take our word for it but how
do we know what Ned said won't come true
how do we know that Ned wasn't
foreshadowing arias future when he said
she would get married and have kids
as a child aria is a lot like her aunt
Lyanna stark there are several different
quotes in the books that compare these
two characters there was another time
Aria had a conversation with Ned and he
compared her to Leona twice this was
when Ned discovered that Aria had a
sword needle and this is what he said
Aria you have a wildness in you child
the wolf's blood my father used to call
it Liana had a touch of it and my
brother Brandon more than a touch it
brought them both to an early grave as
you can see Aria is a lot like Leona as
a child they were both tough who liked
to get dirty and fight and ride horses
and things like that
Ned knows that Aria has this wolf's
blood too and he says that it led to an
early grave for Leona so let's just hope
it doesn't mean the same for Aria but
perhaps this is foreshadowing arias fate
during this same conversation
Genet also says Liana might have carried
a sword if my lord father had allowed it
you remind me of her sometimes you even
look like her when Ned says this Aria
doesn't really think so because people
said Liana was beautiful and no one ever
said Aria was beautiful in fact people
used to make fun of Aria because of the
way she looked she would be called horse
face or lumpy head and things like that
but you have to remember at the time
aria is very young and she's a tomboy
she's always fighting with other boys
and she's always dirty and wearing
raggedy clothes but as Aria gets older
she does become a lot prettier like
Liana so perhaps they were both late
bloomers when Aria is at the house of
black and white we are told that she is
turning into a beautiful young lady
while Aria is there she thinks she has
no other place to go because most of our
family is dead but the kindly man she is
talking to tells her she does have other
options this is what he says you believe
this is the only place for you you are
wrong in that you would find softer
service in the household of some
merchants or you would sooner be a
courtesan and have songs sung of your
beauty speak the word and we will send
you to the Black Pearl or the daughter
of the dusk you will sleep on rose
petals and wear silken skirts that
rustle when you walk in great lords will
beggar themselves for your maidens blood
or if it is marriage and children you
desire tell me and we shall find a
husband for you some honest apprentice
boy a rich old man a Seafarer whatever
you desire no one said these things to
Aria when she was very young but now
that she is getting older she is
starting to change you have to keep in
mind the kindly man is a faceless man he
has seen thousands and thousands of
faces so if he thinks Aria is beautiful
then she probably is the older and more
beautiful aria starts to become her
heart's desire may change in terms of
the things that she wants in her life
Lyanna stark probably faced these same
things when leona was a little girl she
probably never thought of getting
married or settling down at the time she
probably just wanted to ride horses and
train in the practice yard just like
Aria but as she grew
up and became more beautiful she did
decide she wanted other things there are
a few more comparisons in some of the
other chapters Aria is also said to
write a horse just like her own Liana
they both ride horses like Northman and
this shows how they are a lot alike
other than just their looks but we have
already seen examples where people see
Aria and they think of Liana so this
leads me to one a branch chapters in a
dance with dragons I find this one very
interesting because the opposite
actually happens this time bran sees
Liana in a vision but he immediately
thinks he's looking at his sister Aria
as bran is in the weirwood net this is
what he sees two children danced across
the godswood hooting at one another as
they dueled with broken branches the
girl was the older and taller of the two
Aria bran thought eagerly as he watched
her leap up onto a rock and cut at the
boy but that couldn't be right if the
girl was Arya then the boy was brain
himself and he had never worn his hair
so long
Andorian never beat me playing swords
the way that girl is beating him she
slashed the boy across his thigh so hard
that his leg went out from under him and
he fell into the pool and began to
splash and shout you be quiet stupid the
girl said tossing her own branch aside
it's just water
do you want old man to hear and run tell
father now this is very interesting
because brain is actually seeing Liana
and benjin playing around and fighting
this reveals a few things besides Liana
and Aria looking alike this is also an
example of how similar they are in other
ways we know they look alike and we know
they ride horses alike and we know they
both like to fight and now we know they
even talk the same Liana told benjin to
be quiet stupid it's only water do you
want old man to hear and run tell father
now that sounds exactly like something
Oreo would say as I have been thinking
about this lately I have been wondering
if arias story will land in a similar
fashion as Leone has ended the most
interesting thing of all is what is
written in George RR Martin's original
outline before George ever got his first
book published he sent his first 13
chapters to a
friend Ralph and he gave him the basic
outline for what he planned on having
the story be about in that outline we
get a glimpse of what George wanted to
have happen with Aria and it's a perfect
parallel to Liana's own life now I do
have to say that what is written in this
outline has been drastically changed
since then but it's still interesting
nonetheless plus some of the themes have
not changed
George initially wanted Jon Snow and
Arya Stark to fall in love with each
other and even though this has changed
you can still see some remnants of this
in George's story today Jon and Ari are
obviously the closest out of the
siblings because they are always
thinking about each other but it's not
in any kind of a sexual way as he
intended at first but in this original
outline George also wanted Tyrion to
fall in love with Oreo and it says that
John and Tyrians relationship would turn
into a deadly rivalry over Arya Stark
now doesn't that sound a lot like Leone
his own story Robert and Rhaegar was
willing to die for Leona and it looks
like George was gonna have John and
Tyrion willing to die for Arya who is
said to look and act a lot like Leona
thankfully George did change most of his
plans for the story but he did keep some
of the big plot points John's parents
were still kept a secret in Oriya is
still a lot like Liana in this outline
George also stated which five main
characters he wanted to survive the
whole story in Oriya is one of those
characters he planned on having live
throughout everything there is no way to
know if George still intends on having
Arya live or not but he has laid out
some foreshadowing about her death so
perhaps he could have already died at a
very young age like Leona did and this
was something Ned did fear because he
saw that Wolf's blood and Arya just like
he did what Leona but let's say George
or even Dan and Dave will keep Arya
alive if Arya does live how were her
story end will she stay single and
independent like she told her father in
season 1 in book 1 or will she fall in
love like Leona did now that she is
growing up and becoming more beautiful I
know people tend to believe Arya will
never settle down with someone else but
I don't think it's completely out of the
question
Leona was a lot like Oreo
they were young both of them did like to
ride horses get dirty and fight and I
bet lianna never intended on getting
married and having a kid either although
there is no way to know what she thought
as a child but I just had this feeling
that before she had her first period she
probably felt a lot like aurilla did
even though Leon I like to do all the
same things as a child she did grow up
into a beautiful young woman and she did
fall in love and have a child
now unfortunately Aria has led a much
darker life than Liana had to so it
might be harder for her to soften up and
find love but I don't think it's
impossible one of the main reasons why I
ship Aria and Gendry so much is because
of the parallels between Robert and
Liana Robert never got to have the love
of his life because Liana chose Rhaegar
over him but Roberts son Gendry could be
seen as the Robert 2.0 and maybe just
maybe he can find love with Arya who
could be seen as the Liana 2.0 septum or
Dane always said Arya had the hands of a
blacksmith is that George trying to tell
us something or not we were meant to
rule together if your sister had lived
would have been bound by blood well it's
not too late I have a son you have a
daughter
I do want to say when I say arias story
could end like Liana's I don't mean that
Aria will die in a bed of blood just
like her I just mean in terms of her
either dying young likely on a dead or
possibly falling in love like Leon it
did and if she happened to fall in love
with Gendry who is Robert's son it would
be even more poetic but if I learned
anything from Ramsay Bolton it was this
if you think this has a happy ending he
who hasn't even paying attention let me
know what you think about this idea what
do you believe will happen with Arya
Stark at the end of this story
put all your questions and thoughts down
below in the comment section I want to
thank everyone for stopping by to watch
the video I really appreciate that and I
also want to thank everyone on patreon
that supports this channel have a great
day everyone I'll see you soon but
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]